>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Stephen Winick: Welcome.
I'm Steve Winick and we are
here at the Library of Congress
where I will be interviewing
Connie Regan-Blake
with my colleague Valda Morris.
Valda and I both work in the
American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress.
So, I will begin our
interview with Connie.
Connie is a prominent
storyteller.
And so, I'm interested
in your early life
and how you became
interested in storytelling.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Well, I never knew
that this might unfold this way.
When I was in grade school,
high school, I loved math.
I ended up going to
college to get my--
I thought my doctorate in
mathematics and help people,
put people up in a spaceship.
I want to work with NASA.
And things shifted, you
know, as they often do.
I ended up getting a
degree in political science
which some people say is a good
background for storytelling.
But I decided that I didn't
want to go to any more school.
I thought about law school.
And I'd work during the
summers and I'd save my money.
And so, I bought a one way
ticket to Europe and ended
up hitchhiking and
living over there
for about a year and a half.
And when I came back, my
cousin, Barbara Freeman,
who has become my storytelling
partner for 20 years,
she was a librarian,
children's librarian
at a library in Tennessee.
And she told me we are
looking for a storyteller.
You know, it was
unheard of really
to hire a full-time storyteller,
but still it is kind of today.
But that's what they
were looking for.
They'd gotten a federal
grant to take the library
out to daycare centers which
in 1971 was also brand new.
That was a new thing
coming into the world.
And so, they hired me to
tell stories to all three,
four and five-year-olds.
And that was the very beginning.
I was at the library for
four years loving it,
but then decided that what
I really wanted to do was
to travel with storytelling.
And that's when Barbara
and I quit our jobs
and got a pickup
truck and headed out.
>> Valda Morris: So, you
bought a pickup truck?
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
That's right.
>> Valda Morris:
That's interesting.
Why a pickup truck?
Not-- Why not a car?
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Well, we put a--
I used to call it a camper.
But someone said
it's not a camper.
It's tiny.
It's a topper.
So, that's what we actually
lived out of for three years.
>> Valda Morris: So,
how was it on the road?
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
It was amazing.
You know, I look back on it now
and a lot of people will say
when they've heard story
or during those days even,
they would say, you sure are
putting in your time or you're--
you know, as if it
was a big hardship.
But I'll tell you, everywhere
we went, people opened
up their hearts and their homes.
They end up inviting us on stage
and it was a marvelous
adventure.
And there were certain times
when, you know, it was pouring
down rain and we had to get
out to make a phone call to see
if that nursery school-- make
sure we have the right address
to go there the next
morning to tell stories
or to the local college
to teach a workshop.
So, there were some
of those moments.
But we actually devised a
system called business weeks.
And so, we would
each take a week.
And that meant if it was raining
and it was your week,
you had to get out.
You had to make sure
that truck was locked.
But in general, the experience
on being on the road then
and meeting people in the folk
world and in the library world
and just in the world
in the general,
people just welcomed us.
>> Valda Morris: And how long
were you on the road for?
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Three years.
You know, again, when
I think about that,
it's like, how did we do that?
>> Valda Morris: Yeah.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
But, you know,
we didn't have almost any money.
We put money we had.
We needed to have it take us a
long way and mostly pay for gas.
And we actually did not
end up staying in the back
of that truck all that much
because often, librarians
or people that ran the
festivals, you know,
they always had extra bedrooms
or would say you can crash
on the floor or something.
But we always had
that as a backup.
So, it wasn't like every time
we were traveling, it was like,
you know, because we never
could've afforded hotels
and things.
And so, it was great
having the truck
for that reason especially.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
So, one of the figures that
comes up in your descriptions
of your own sort of life
in storytelling is Ray
Hicks and his family.
How was it that you
came to meet Ray
and what was his
influence on you?
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Enormous
influence and enormous influence
to this day, continuous.
I met him at the very first
National Storytelling Festival.
And a friend had told
me about that festival
and I wrote the person
that was--
Jimmy Neil Smith who has become
the director and a leader
of the first organization.
And I wrote him and said
I'm a storyteller and I live
in Chattanooga down the
road from Jonesborough.
And he wrote me a letter
and said, come on up.
We'll put you on the stage.
S, I told Barbara.
I said, we got to go up there.
And so, we went to this
festival on a Sunday afternoon
and I remember the moment
that they introduced Ray.
And he walked up on stage,
all six feet seven inches tall
and he had on those
bib overalls.
He always had one gallus open,
had a can of Prince
Albert tobacco
and he would roll his
cigarettes, you know,
and had harmonica in there.
And as soon as he was finished,
they transported all of us
that day into another world.
And when the storytelling was
finished, Barbara and I went
up to meet Ray and
his wife Rosa.
And we walked around
downtown Jonesborough.
And he told us Wicked
John and the Devil.
We asked him lots of questions.
And that began this
long friendship.
Actually, Rosa in later
years because I was--
really they were-- we were
like family until each
of them passed away, and
that was in the 2000s.
So, I got a good chunk
of time with them.
And I remember Rosa telling me.
She said that she had fallen
in love with me that day
as we walked around
Jonesborough.
And so then, we found out--
you know, I found out where
they lived in every chance.
I got both with Barbara
and just on my own.
And then after folk tellers
came to a close in '95,
I kept up a real
relationship with him.
And I felt like there's
so much to say about Ray.
But to try to put it into
a sentence or two, it was--
he did open a lot of windows
for me and showed me a path
to storytelling that
really is of the heart
and of the whole body.
He was one of the most
present storytellers I've
ever encountered.
And I feel like that's
just one of the many gifts
that he gave me because that's
something I really aimed for to.
It's not this memorized text
or it's not, you know, yeah,
I'm going to tell that
story or it's right there.
It's brand new for him.
You could just see it
unfolding in that moment.
So, it was-- I am so glad
my life has been enriched
in so many ways because
of the Hicks family.
>> Valda Morris: OK.
So obviously, Ray has-- had
a lasting impression on you.
Do you have any other mentors
or any other traditional
storytellers
that would play a
role that Ray did?
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Not anything quite
on that same place.
There certainly have been people
that have influenced
me in wonderful ways.
Kathryn Windham who was not
really telling stories exactly
then, but had been a journalist,
came from that background.
And she and I became
deer friends.
And she had a directness
about her.
It's not-- She's a southerner--
She was a southerner.
She was born and
raised in Selma.
And so, she had that
[inaudible] about her,
but also this directness
that she would just
cut through things.
So, I feel like she taught
me a lot in that area too.
And, you know, Jackie
Torrence became a good friend
and she taught me a lot
about using my hands
when I tell stories.
She was fantastic at that.
>> Valda Morris: Yeah.
She was good for the gestures.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Yes.
I feel like I've learned from
a lot of people along the way,
and also from a lot
of folk musicians.
Because when we first
started telling, when Barbara
and I were traveling
in that little truck,
there was only two festivals,
storytelling festivals
in the United States.
And so, we were mostly being
invited on to the stages
at folk music festivals.
And there were so many people
that went to bat for us
because back then, it wasn't
just sending a text to him.
It was sitting down
and writing a letter,
making a long distance call to
the Winnipeg Folk Festival or,
you know, out to Vancouver,
out to San Diego or something.
It took a lot more effort.
And everywhere we went, as we
met people and people heard us,
they really, you know,
said to other people,
you got to hire these two, you
got to put them on main stage.
And-- Because I think
then if any--
We didn't really know anyone
telling stories, but--
except Marshall Dodge.
Now, he was another influence.
Oh gosh, and we just--
we all fell in love,
you know, with each other.
It was just amazing, what
an extraordinary unusual man
he was.
But he was the only-- And he
called himself a humorist.
But he was the only that was
kind of on that folk circuit.
But a lot of people-- At that
time, it really took a couple
of decades before this shifted.
When people heard the word
storytellers and storytelling,
they immediately went
to children thinking
that it was only for children.
It certainly is for children.
But I think all of the people
that helped us in so many ways,
they're the ones that
told the festival folks,
you got to put them
on main stage
because this is for adults.
This is for everyone,
but it's for adults.
Don't just put them
in the children's.
Put them there too.
But put them-- And I
think that was a huge gift
because it could've turned
out very differently.
It could've still been,
you know, a great ride.
But I think it would've
turned out very differently.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
Well, you mentioned before the
National Storytelling Festival
and your first experience there.
Could you expand on
that on how that was--
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Oh gosh.
Yes. So when I'd written
Jimmy Neil and actually
in the archives have a copy
of the letter he wrote me back
in 1973 and saying, you
know, yeah, come on up.
And if we have time,
we'll put you on.
So on that Sunday afternoon
after Ray had told stories,
some politicians had gotten
up and there was some music,
they asked if anyone
wanted to tell a story
and I raised my hand and
went right up and told one.
And then I've been involved
in the Cosby Folk Festival.
It's actually around
John McCutcheon
in '72 I think it was.
But I've been involved there
and had told some
stories there as well.
And through this wonderful
confluence of events,
I ended up back in Jonesborough
because I met an amazing woman,
grandam of Jonesborough,
Caroline Moore,
and I went up to
visit her and it was
about a month before the
second storytelling festival.
And when I pulled up
into her driveway,
she had a dramatic
flair about her.
And she didn't even
let me get inside.
She just said, Connie,
come with me.
And I got into the
car and she drove me
down to Jimmy Neil
Smith's office.
And she opened the door to
the kitchen of the restaurant
that he was running at the
time, The Parson's Table.
She opened the door and said,
Jimmy Neil, here she is.
And she closed the door.
And I wasn't quite
sure what that meant.
Come to find out.
She must have called
him or something.
But he then said, will you
come and be a storyteller
at the second national?
So, that was in a month.
I said I'd be delighted
to and I was.
And then at the third, I think
the third, by the end, Barbara
and I had quit our jobs
and we were featured.
And I actually-- You
might already know this.
But I actually have, that I'm
so proud of, a distinct honor
of being the only person, the
only storyteller to be on stage
at all 45 festivals so far.
>> Valda Morris: Wow.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: So,
I have been on stage either
as a featured teller or as
an emcee every single year.
And I'm going back this
year as a featured teller.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
Congratulations.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: I
have quite a history there.
Yeah.
>> Valda Morris: That's
quite an accomplishment.
OK. So, you have been involved
in the national storytelling
scene now what we call the
national storytelling revival.
How did you see the scene
growing and changing over time?
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Well,
you know, in those early days,
as Jimmy Neil used to say,
he ran the fourth
there in Jonesborough.
And Barbara and I, I think I
was never on stage without--
all these festivals, music
events, coffee houses and things
like that without telling
people about that festival.
And in some ways, it grew in
this wonderful way because if--
there had been 3,000
people the second year,
it might have fallen apart
because they couldn't
have handled it.
But it was 150, and
then it went up to 400
and it kept growing till
today to where there's
about 10,000 people
or something.
But it's changed a lot, you
know, this net of storytellers
that goes out across the United
States and across the world now.
It brings in lots
of different people.
In the United States, a real
shift happened in the 1980s
where people started
telling a lot
of personal experience stories.
Before then, it was
all traditional.
You would maybe tell
a little bit about--
you know, I might tell about
Ray and how I got this story,
but your stories or all
the traditional stories,
those ones that have been around
hundreds or thousands of years.
And in the late 80s,
that started shifting.
And I think that
shift has maintained.
And now, there's a lot of people
telling funny stories on stage
about themselves
or their childhood.
And I really like a blending.
I love now.
It's a wonderful
experience to be--
I tell not so much about
my fourth grade teacher,
but more about my own adventures
traveling around the world
and I also tell some true life
stories about historical figures
or people that I've met who
had amazing lives or something.
So, I don't tell
all traditional.
But I really like
the interweaving.
And I think we're
missing something by a lot
of people turning
away from tradition.
And one thing that we're missing
is introducing our listeners
to these traditional
stories because, you know,
they might have that same
idea that we used to have
about storytelling
is only for kids.
They might have that idea.
Traditional stories
are a little boring
or who would want to
really tell those.
But if they could see some of
their favorite storytellers
and see more of them or go to
an event and in the evening hear
at least half traditional
stories,
I think it could
really change things.
Not only for storytellers
coming up in what they're doing,
but there's something
about the old stories.
There's a reason they've
been told for these hundreds,
sometimes thousands of years.
It resonates in us.
There's something in our
DNA that wants to hear those
and then often wants
to tell them.
And if we turn away from that,
I think we're losing a
richness as human beings.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
I know what you mean.
And you definitely have observed
something there in that shift
to personal stories which
I think nowadays for a lot
of people, that's what
storytelling means.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: I
think that's what it is.
>> Valda Morris: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: -- and
all of those radio programs--
>> Connie Regan-Blake: I
remember a poignant letter
that I got during
some of this shift.
And it was from a
seventh grade teacher.
And it was after the National
Storytelling Festival.
This was maybe in the 1990s.
And she said, you know, I used
to always be able to come back
after a weekend in Jonesborough
and tell the stories
to my students.
Now, I can't tell
them because they're
about somebody else's
experience when I went swimming.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: You know.
The other thing that I'll
mention and I'm heartened
by this is that this is
only in the United States.
You know, in Ireland, I was
in a festival last year,
this time actually, the
Cape Clear Festival,
it's almost all traditional
stories.
And you go down to New
Zealand or Australia,
you're hearing traditional
stories,
and other places all
around the world.
So, it seems that America
is the one that's gone more
on this path.
And I love that people
are listening to The Moth,
having StorySLAMs, but I would
just want that room, you know,
to invite the old stories
up there with us too.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
Well, going back to your
experience with Barbara
as the folk tellers,
you and Barbara
to a certain extent have
different storytelling styles.
So, how did you-- Could
you explain a little bit
of the dynamics of creating
a story with the two of you?
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Well, it was very easy.
All we would do what we
called tandem stories.
And now, there are tandem--
a lot of tandem tellers.
So, that's-- that phrase is
still definitely out there.
But we would swap
lines back and forth
and then say words together
and then go back to swapping
and telling one story together.
We also told our
individual stories.
So, an evening would
include all of that.
But in these tandem stories,
sometimes people would say, oh,
I bet you really have
to practice those
and your timing is so precise.
But we likened it more
to family gospel singers.
You know, their voices
just kind of go right in
and there is almost
this intuitive sense.
So, we would, you know,
work out a story sometimes
when we were driving around
those first three years.
We decide who would
say what, you know,
and kind of work on things.
But it was not this laborious,
oh, we got to figure this out.
It just was-- You know,
it's kind of there.
It was clear and we would
just go right into it
and our voice is clicking.
I think because we're
related, we're first cousins.
That might be part of it.
And so, that's not any kind
of an effort which is lovely.
>> Valda Morris:
So, you have a--
you had a play which ran for
a couple of years as well?
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Yes.
Yes.
>> Valda Morris: Can you
please tell us about that play.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Oh boy, it was great.
The reason-- The impetus for
the play, I had gotten married
to my dear sweet husband Phil.
And I wanted to stay
in Asheville more.
I didn't want to be
traveling quite as much.
And Barbara was up for
hanging around more too.
And so, we wrote this play.
We thought first that--
we didn't ever thought
about it being a play.
We thought it would be an
evening of our stories,
but more polished in
deciding ahead of time
which stories we would tell,
how they would unfold
for the evening.
And so, we asked a dear
friend, John Basinger, to come
and help us put that together.
And it was in the summer time
and he brought his
daughter, Savannah Basinger.
And what ended up unfolding
out of that was this play
about our great aunt Jenny.
It's part fictional,
part our own biography.
And then, we interwove all
the stories that we wanted to.
We co-wrote it, the four of us.
And we called it Mountain
Sweet Talk and it ran
for seven seasons in Asheville,
over 300 performances.
And actually, I love these
little titles and such,
but it actually is still
Asheville's longest running
theatrical production.
But-- And my husband Phil was--
he would do sounds and lights.
We had other friends who would
hire people to help on that.
And his mom, my mother-in-law,
worked the door.
She would take tickets.
And it was a very different
experience for us to be
on stage doing same words
almost every night and knowing
that a light cue or a sound cue
for a fiddle to come in depended
on a particular word,
you know, a saying
or a phrase or something.
So, that was a different
experience.
But we really both
got into it, you know.
We both really enjoyed it.
It kind of got right inside
of us and it was lovely being
at home that much
and not traveling.
>> Valda Morris: So,
you performed it
during the summer time?
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Yes, in the fall.
So, Asheville is a
big tourist place.
The theater was at the Folk
Art Center which is right
on Blue Ridge Parkway.
And we got a lot of
folks from out of town.
We also got a lot
of repeat visitors
that would come and hear it.
And we started keeping a list of
frequent buyers, we called it,
and we gave them
a little discount.
And we had some people that saw
it 23 times, that was the most.
>> Stephen Winick: Wow.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: And they
would plan their family reunions
when-- so they would call
us like in April or March
and say now, what are the
dates for this summer and fall,
and then they would plan
events or have guest come in.
So, we had a grand reception
there in North Carolina for it.
>> Stephen Winick:
Wow that's great.
So eventually, you and
Barbara parted ways.
The folk teller stopped
being an act per se.
How did that come about
and was that just organic?
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Well,
we both took very different
paths in the early '90s.
And Barbara-- Well, maybe I
described some of this as well,
but she kind of took a
path back to Catholicism,
and that became the
main focus of her life
and as she would self
describe as a pretty out there
on the edge, especially
from my perspective.
And so even as far as some of
the stories that she wanted
to tell and whether to continue
telling some of the stories
that we were already telling,
she was feeling maybe not
so much this one because
it has that mention.
So, that was part of
it and we just got
on such different tracks that
I know it was a hard decision.
I had only been on stage except
for an emcee, as being an emcee.
I think I had only been on stage
telling stories once or twice
in 20 years without her.
And I remember thinking, when do
you drink water, when do you--
how do you do this one
after another, you know.
So, it was really emotional
and it was a hard decision
to come to, but there was--
I was very grateful that I
had a clarity, that this was--
we were on different paths.
And so, one of my images was
that we were both opening doors
for each other to go
on a solo journey,
and that's what we've done.
And it has-- You know,
I'm hoping Barbara will
say the same thing.
But, you know, she's the one
that brought me into
storytelling.
And I am so grateful for my life
unfolding in that way and I look
to Barbara with all
the gratitude for that.
But the next 23 years now
have unfolded in amazing ways
that I am so grateful
that I made that shift
and made that decision.
>> Valda Morris: Well,
tonight's program is going
to have you guys back
on the stage again.
So, tell me what it
is like preparing
for this concert tonight.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Well,
we did a concert one other time
at the national festival.
I think it's been about
maybe 10 years ago.
And I was featured there
that year and I asked,
would you all be up for a
folk teller performance?
And Barbara was up for it.
People in the festival were too.
And that time and this
time, so those are the--
these will be the only
two times, that was once.
This is only the second time.
And we do some things
at family reunions,
but not on stage behind mics.
But the same has
happened this time,
it did when we were
preparing for that.
You know, we just went--
flowed right back into it.
It was-- I mean, we'll
see what happens tonight
and how it unfolds.
But I think it's such body
memory in some way that starting
into it and-- because we're
doing familiar stories.
We're doing our old chestnuts
as they say, I guess.
But I don't know if I
necessarily like that word
for it, but our old
favorites really,
and that's what we've
picked on to tell tonight.
And I think it's
going to be good.
I think, you know, our
voices are right there,
like aged in similar
ways, I guess.
>> Valda Morris: We are
looking forward to it for sure.
>> Stephen Winick: Absolutely.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Thank you.
>> Stephen Winick:
So, you mentioned some
of your favorite stories.
What are your favorite
kinds of stories to tell
and if you wouldn't mind
mentioning some specific
examples of your
top stories maybe.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Sure.
Well, one story that
became such a favorite story
of mine was the one that
I heard Ray tell walking
through the streets
of Jonesborough,
Wicked John and the Devil.
I had this-- You know,
I love that image
of doors opening
and windows opening.
And so, there was another
door that opened as Barbara
and I were bringing
folk teller to a close.
And that was the Kandinsky Trio.
And they are a chamber
music trio
and they were looking
for a storyteller.
Their agent thought
it would be great
for the chamber music world and
the storytelling world to bring
on a storyteller and have some
original music be written.
And so, I met with them
and interviewed and such
and they heard my recordings and
brought me on board for that.
And we picked a version that I
came up with with Ray's help.
It was very similar
to his version.
But Ray helped me a lot on
it and inspired me in ways,
not helped maybe in ways that we
would think helping on a story,
but we can get into
that if you'd like.
But we called it the
Cantankerous Blacksmith.
It was a version of
Wicked John and the Devil.
And the intention
was that the four
of us tell it all
on stage together.
So, it wasn't music and some
storytelling for interest,
or it wasn't vocal with
this music as background.
The four of us were telling it.
So sometimes, the cellist was
telling it, sometimes I was,
sometimes all four of us.
And Mike Reid is the person that
wrote the original music for it.
He was a football
hero at Penn State.
And then, he left there and went
to the Cincinnati
Bengals, NFL football.
And at the height of his career,
he quit because he didn't
want anything to happen
to his fingers because
he loved the piano.
So, they chose him
as the composer.
And I met with him first
in Nashville, Tennessee.
He went on to become--
He's still a songwriter
and a musician and has written--
you know, received Grammies
from Bonnie Raitt and lots
of different people,
written things for the Judds.
So, he's the one that
wrote the music for it.
And we-- Right away when
we started working on that,
it was again almost
like that tandem.
I hadn't thought of that before,
but almost like that
tandem with Barbara.
After our first weekend
of rehearsal,
six months before our
first performance,
we all felt like we could
go out on stage and do this.
And we opened at Penn State,
that a thousand people
in the audience, the largest
audience they'd ever had
for chamber music and they came
because of Mike being
the football hero there,
and then that took me on
this other whole adventure.
So, working on Wicked
John and the Devil,
in that way with music,
with that classical music
which I didn't know at
all, I remember them saying
when we were talking about--
when I would come in and he
said, oh, you can just look
over my shoulder
and see the music.
I said, well, I don't
read music, you know.
So, I've had these
images for the music
of where I would then come in.
And one of the highlights of my
life was Ray Hicks coming to one
of those performances.
There's emotion there.
And I didn't know he
didn't have a cellphone.
And I've written him we were
going to be performing it.
And the very first season--
We went on for nine
seasons with that show.
But at the very first season,
Appalachian State in Boone,
North Carolina had invited--
you know, they were one of the
presenting performance places.
And so, I've written
a letter to Rosa.
That's-- She and I
always correspond.
I've got lots of letters
from Rosa in the collection.
But I had written her, but I
had no idea if they were going
to be able to make it.
And I'd given them a few
suggestions of who might be able
to drive them and
they had no phones
and they had to work
all that out.
They didn't have
any car, anything.
And, boy, when we
walked out on that stage,
it was a full theater
filled with people.
But-- And we were-- I wore a tux
with pants, so this fancy kind
of shiny, white with
a black tux over it
with a few little sparkles on it
and trio was all in their vest.
The four of us walked out and
I saw Ray in that second row
and it was quite an experience.
And he listened to that
story with an open heart.
Yeah, there was about eight
of them that were there.
And he just would laugh and
slap his leg and it was just--
to bring that back right
now to see how open he was
to new experience, to hear
this traditional story
that he had known since he
was five years old being told
with a chamber music, trio and
a violin and piano and cello.
And afterwards, I'll tell
you, I walked him out
and he-- I remember standing.
They had parked in a garage.
And I remember standing
right there
as we were saying our goodbyes.
And he told me how much he'd
enjoyed the performance.
And he said, Connie,
don't let them forget
about me when I'm gone.
And then he said, you,
Connie, that's how he used
to say my name, Connie,
you tell on, tell on.
And that's my license
plate right now
with an exclamation point, North
Carolina, tell on, tell on.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
>> Valda Morris: Wow.
OK. So your stories, I
guess rather your stories
and albums have won many
awards for ELE given example.
So, where do you get
your story material from?
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Well,
I have a new one coming
out literally in three weeks.
It will be in time for
the national festival.
It's called Leap and Laugh,
exclamation point,
Tales of Adventure.
And so, I have-- I actually
have this experience that I went
on I was invited to tell
in-- down in New Zealand.
And after telling
stories, my husband
and I took a two-week
trip throughout the north
and south island.
And I ended up getting
with a parapenter.
Do you know what that is?
Being strapped on.
He was behind me.
Parachute on the ground.
And he reached over my shoulder
and said, Connie, jog, jog, jog.
And I started running towards
the cliff and we went off
into the air over Queenstown.
So, that's the link
part of the story.
So, that's a personal
experience story and adventure.
And that story is on there as
well as an old Scottish tale
that was being told at
the time of Shakespeare.
And it's called the
Well of True Water.
There's a story about
my husband.
That is-- I named it Dorky
Spandex versus Macho Leather.
And it's about his bicycle rod
going up to Mount Mitchell,
the tallest peak east
of the Mississippi,
and these motorcyclists
that were passing him
on their motorbikes.
So, there's both
personal experience
and traditional stories,
lots of humor.
That will be a new thing for me.
The focus on this in
some ways is humor.
So, that CD is coming out
with a digital download.
That will be my first CD
to actually have a
digital download included
which is kind of cool.
And then, I have
some general stories.
I have some stories about
Ray that's on my Dive,
Into Stories CD,
so those CDs, so.
>> Stephen Winick: So once
you've come up with a story
or found a story, how do you
craft it into a performance?
>> Connie Regan-Blake: So, this
has evolved over the years.
And what happens now
and probably the last 10
or 15 years, I have this idea
about a story and they come
to me in different ways.
One story, I was reading
a newspaper article.
I was heading down
to visit my parents
in Jacksonville, Florida.
And I read a newspaper article
about a woman who was now living
in St. Augustine, Florida
who had been a spy
during World War II.
She was English.
At 17, had learned how to fly
and she helped get
people out of Dunkirk.
And extraordinary story, I
went down and interviewed her
and I called her, interviewed
her in St. Augustine.
And for whatever reason,
that story got put
on a back burner two years ago.
So, that's one that
I'm now telling
at the national festival.
So, some stories are like that.
So, they're more historical
or true life events.
Some are about myself.
But when I'm working on them,
sometimes there's just a nugget.
And I have a group of
friends, other storytellers,
Jay O'Callahan, Beth
Horner, Milbre Burch
that we work on Skype.
We get together sometimes
in person.
We also work on Skype.
And we have devised this method.
I'll tell you just briefly
about the Blue Lakers.
I don't know if you know
about those people yet.
But they are a group of
national storytellers
and we started meeting over 30
years ago and we spend a week
with each other every
year for 30 years.
And that's Bill Harley,
[inaudible], Jim May,
Jay O'Callahan, David Holt,
all these amazing stories.
>> Valda Morris:
-- storytellers.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Yes,
Beth Horner and Milbre.
And so, we developed this whole
way of working on stories.
And then, each of us kind of
tweaked it to our own versions.
But what my version is now is
I might be working with Jay
or Beth on Skype or in person
is even better, but Skype works.
And we'll just-- I have
lined up, you could look
at my calendar now and
see the time is coming
up in the next month and
a half that I'm going
to be working with them.
And it might be that this
particular afternoon,
we are each taking 45 minutes.
We always have our timer.
And so, I take say
the first 45 minutes
and it might be I'm
working on a colonel.
All I have is, boy, this
amazing thing happened to Phil
on this bike rod going
up to Mount Mitchell.
So, I'm just talking about
it and I record myself.
Nowadays, the last
however many years,
it's on my phone, a voice memo.
And I record even as I'm
thinking out loud about it.
So, this is just
literally the, I don't know,
but this might happen
or what-- you know.
And then when I finish up,
because I've been telling,
I can [inaudible] make it
sound like a story right away.
It comes to a close the very
first thing in my system
of this way of working
on stories is I give
myself an appreciation.
What did I like about that?
Well, I really liked it
when I talked about him.
Putting on that helmet
that's dorky
and that little tiny
mirror like a dentist,
what happened to your mouth.
And so, I really like that.
So-- And then whoever
I'm working with,
they tell me what they liked.
And then, we go back to any
tweaks, what can make it better?
I think I'll investigate
about a motorcycle, you know,
how is it that they end up--
you know, what would
they be wearing.
I guess if Phil is on the
ground looking up trying
to get his feet unclipped from
those bike clips on his bicycle
and this guy is backing up.
He might look like
he weighs 350 pounds.
So, I might say some of that
out loud, and then that is all
on that tape as I'm
working with Beth on it.
And she might have
some suggestions.
And then at some point, I go
to text, so it's typed out,
but I never think
of it as a script.
It's not, oh, it's those words.
Because each time of the
telling, especially the next 8,
10, 20 times, and I'll be
doing this tonight with one
of the stories I'm telling, I'll
have my phone on stage with me.
I've got a little microphone.
So, I'm recording and then
I'll go back to that text.
See, I like things better the
way I actually did it as it,
you know, was happening on
stage with the listeners.
And that's been the biggest
lesson for me on working
on stories is knowing
that I need a listener.
I can't go into an empty
room and sit and go, OK.
I go back to fourth grader,
blank page in front on me.
I don't have anything to say.
But if somebody walks
in the door,
sometimes it's my assistant.
You know, I'm working on a story
with or more often it's some
of these other storytellers.
>> Valda Morris: Great.
All right.
>> Stephen Winick: Well, so
we're going to talk a little bit
about your collection
because one of the things
that we're very excited about at
the American Folklife Center is
that we have a collection
of your materials.
So, just give us an
overview of what's
in the collection
that you gave to us.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Gosh, Steve, you know,
when I look back especially now
that you know the story of us,
doing all this traveling,
literally only having
that little truck
and not much stories.
My sister's place in Atlanta
was a place we would drop
things off.
But I think of it as a little
blessing or a little grace
that I saved all
these pieces of paper.
And I would make copies
before I sent letters out.
So if we were writing
different festivals or--
because all of it mostly was
done through writing and sitting
and through the mail, I
get copies of all of that.
And then Barbara and I, we
would do touring schedules.
We would send out three
months worth of schedules
and we would sit down
and handwrite this.
Eventually I had
somebody working for us.
I get copies of all those.
So, I've got notes from my
correspondents back and forth
with Jimmy Neil, correspondents
with Maurice Sendak
and Ezra Jack Keats, you know,
two famous children's book
authors, and Ashley Ryan,
correspondents, I've kept
all that correspondents.
My mother kept all
of my correspondents.
So, a lot of that talks
about storytelling.
A lot of it is personal and
what's happening at home.
But we mostly communicated
by mail
and we would do general
delivery.
So, we'd walk into Vermont
at the post office and say,
could I have my mail, please?
And they'd go back and find
Connie and Barbara and bring it
out and we'd sit on the steps.
They were at the Philadelphia
main post office downstairs,
that-- downtown, that
magnificent building.
I remember going out on the
steps outside, you know,
and [inaudible], what's
folk teller, what's Connie,
what's Barbara, you know.
And so, I've saved
all those letters.
I've saved every program.
I think I'm the only one that
has a program from all 45
of the national storytelling
festivals and,
you know, posters.
And so, that's what
I've been sending.
Plus a lot of correspondents,
I have always enjoyed.
The calendars that we kept
weren't just, here we do this.
You know, I'd often put a little
reflection, not exactly diaries.
There's a few diaries,
but not so much of that,
but a few moments of--
or how that was or maybe a
little drawing or something.
So, I've saved all of
that, all of the stuff
with the Kandinsky Trio.
I saved long before knowing that
this was even a possibility.
So, I'm thrilled and I've
got a lot more to say.
Yes. I'm hoping to
do some more soon,
and then you guys will get
all of them once I got it.
>> Valda Morris: Great.
So if somebody was coming
here to the library to look
at your collection, what would
you tell them to look for?
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Gosh.
Well, there's going to be a lot
of photos of the Hicks Family.
That jumps in my mind.
And something that I kind of
thought of, I've kept a copy
of every single promotional
piece of material that we had
as the folk tellers all the
way through my solo career.
And I actually thought
about that at one point
that that might be cool for
someone that is an artist
or a designer to go back and
just see what is that sheet
of paper that was
mimeographed with a photograph
and a few quotes at the bottom
that Bill Dumler [assumed
spelling] up in Hartford,
Connecticut helped
us put together.
In addition to running
that festival up there
in the coffee house,
he ran a copy company,
you know, a little shop.
So, he was literally the one.
He got Sandy Payton who
had folk legacy records
to give us a quote because
he had heard us tell stories.
And what would that be like for
a designer to come in and see
that first page up to
my business cards now
that have that, you know,
soft feeling and rounded edges
and to see that whole
progression.
So, that's just one tiny way
and certainly storytellers,
you know, that's what I'm hoping
that people will be inspired
to tell their own stories
traditional and personal
and not only necessarily
thinking of it on stage,
but how can they do that with
their family, how can do they do
that in their community.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
Well, we've reached the
point where we say thank you.
But we also ask whether
there's anything that you would
like to add, that
you want to add
for the record in
this interview.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
You know, I would really
like to thank Todd for being the
one that pursued this with me
to do this collection.
You know, I called him
up because I came upon old
cassettes of some of the people
from the folk music
world, Red Clay Ramblers,
some of the performers
back because I was there
with my little cassette
recorder recording people back
in the early days as
well as Ray and such.
But a lot of musicians, I want
to keep the storytelling ones.
But I thought, you know,
Todd might want this.
And I called him and that's
when this started unfolding.
So, I'd really like
to thank him.
And thank you guys.
You got good questions.
>> Stephen Winick:
Well, thank you.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
My memory is rolling.
>> Stephen Winick: I should
clarify that Connie is talking
about Todd Harvey who is
our acquisitions coordinator
at the American Folklife Center.
And this is where you can
find this wonderful collection
of material relating to
storytelling and to the career
of Connie Regan-Blake.
So, thank you very much
on behalf of myself
and Valda Morris and the
American Folklife Center.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: I thank
anyone who's listening to this.
I hope that you will
tell stories.
>> Stephen Winick: Tell on.
Tell on.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Exactly.
>> So, you want to ask?
>> Stephen Winick: So, we have--
Feel free to say no
to this request, but--
and also it may not be
necessary because of things.
So to explain, we do a lot
of programming on our blog
and our podcast around
Halloween.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: And so,
I was wondering if you plan
to tell any stories
with the kind
of supernatural focus tonight.
And if not, would you be willing
to tell one at some point here
in this studio for us
to put in the podcast.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Oh, absolutely.
And actually, I'm like
99% sure that I'm going
to tell Two White
Horses tonight--
>> [Simultaneously] OK.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
-- which is--
you know, would be
perfect for that.
But-- Because I need to--
You all kind of need to know
because I need to do
something else for the podcast.
Yeah, I'm sure because
that's the story that I feel.
It's the one that help
people see this was
for adults and for--
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: --
you know, the festivals
and such, festival audiences.
So, I am going to tell that one.
>> Stephen Winick: OK.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: So you'll
get that and you'll be glad.
I'll be delighted
when you do that.
>> -- John the Devil?
>> Stephen Winick:
Wicked John and the Devil.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
So, that's a 22-minute story.
And that's actually not scary.
It's not a Halloween story.
Yeah. It's--
[ Inaudible ]
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Oh,
there'd be a lot of other ones.
>> Valda Morris: Mr. Fox.
Yeah. Mr. Fox is a good one.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: I mean,
Mary Culhane and Rag Doll and--
I mean, there's a
lot of other ones.
But I think Two White Horses
would be perfect, don't you?
>> That's great.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
Yeah. As long as there's
something we would love--
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
It definitely has that.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
All right.
>> Halloween is very,
very special [laugher].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Stephen Winick: We started
our blog at Halloween just
by coincidence really, but it's
becoming this kind of thing
in the Folklife Center.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
So, do you--
So the blog, do you
have-- is it a video?
Is it a long video?
>> Stephen Winick:
Well, it's mostly--
So, the only way we can put
this video on the blog is
if it's already online
at the library website.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick:
So for example,
I can blog this webcast
once it goes online.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: And we will.
But otherwise, it's-- mostly
what we can put up is audio.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: So,
I'll give you one of my CDs.
So, I've got the chilling
ghost stories with me.
>> Stephen Winick:
That would be good.
>> Valda Morris: That's great.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick:
As long as you're OK
with putting one
of those online.
Yeah.
>> Connie Regan-Blake:
Oh absolutely.
Yeah. Yeah.
And if you let me know about
it, I'll do social media--
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: --
to let you know when
that's coming up in October.
>> Valda Morris: Awesome.
>> Connie Regan-Blake: Yeah.
>> Valda Morris: Thanks Connie.